.
RAISING CONCERNS ABOUT BRIGHTLY
COLORED FENTANYL PILLS FOUND IN
PACKAGING THAT LOOKS LIKE CANDY.
TWO MEN ARRESTED AFTER SELLING
RAINBOW COLORED FENTANYL PILLS
INSIDE CANDY BOXES LIKE NERDS
AND SKITTLES.
AND DEA OFFICIALS BELIEVE IT IS
THE CARTEL'S WAY TO TARGET
CHILDREN AS YOUNG AS MIDDLE
SCHOOL.
EVEN TOP DEMOCRAT LEADERS LIKE
CHUCK SCHUMER ARE SOUNDING THE
ALARM.
>> THIS IS A PICTURE OF
FENTANYL.
THESE ARE SWEET TARTS.
IF YOU OPENED UP THIS LITTLE
CONTAINER OF SWEET TARTS, IT
WOULD LOOK ABOUT THE SAME.
THAT IS WHAT THE DRUG DEALERS
ARE DOING.
THEY SAY, "THIS WILL GIVE YOU A
GREAT HIGH AND IT LOOKS
INNOCENT."
THAT SO THE KIDS ARE FAR MORE
LIKELY TO TAKE IT.
HALLOWEEN IS COMING UP, YOU
KNOW, THIS IS THE KIND OF TIME
KIDS ARE INVOLVED WITH CANDY AND
ALL KINDS OF OTHER THINGS.
THAT IS REALLY WORRISOME AND
VERY DANGEROUS.
>> Judge Jeanine: YOU
KNOW, BRIAN, WE HAVE A FENTANYL
DEATH RELATED IN THIS COUNTRY
EVERY 9 MINUTES.
YOU HAVE CHUCK SCHUMER OVER
THERE SOUNDING THE ALARM.
ISN'T HE SOUNDING THE ALARM, I
MEAN, I'M HAPPY HE'S TALKING
ABOUT IT, BUT SHOULDN'T HE BE
SOUNDING THE ALARM WITH THE
WHITE HOUSE?
SHOULDN'T THE WHITE HOUSE BE
TALKING ABOUT THE FACT THIS IS
HAPPENING OR WOULD IT BE TOO
DANGEROUS?
>> Brian: HE WANTS TO REPENT
FROM THE HEADLINE, IT LOOKS LIKE
SWEET TARTS, SKITTLES, NERDS.
IF HE REALLY CARED, CHINA TO THE
CARTEL ACROSS THE BORDER INTO
YOUR BEDROOM AND INTO YOUR
LIVING ROOM INTO YOUR DORM ROOM.
THAT IS WHAT HE WOULD SEE IF HE
REALLY CARED.
THIS IS NOT HARD.
WHAT I THINK IT IS NOTEWORTHY,
THEY ARE NOT LOOKING TO GET A
LONG-TERM CUSTOMER.
THEY ARE LOOKING TO KILL.
SO, IF SOMEBODY IS GOING TO KILL
YOU, WHY DO YOU NEED A SECOND
SOURCE?
STOP IT!
WE KNOW HOW IT IS DONE.
GREAT PROGRESS WAS MADE WITH A
DIFFERENT PRESIDENT.
NOW YOU NEED TO ERADICATE THE
PROBLEM BUT IT CERTAINLY WORTH A
PROBLEM.
>> Judge Jeanine: JESSE, THE
TRUTH IS IT IS UGLY BY CHINA AND
NOW AMERICAN CHILDREN.
AND IF THEY CARE, THE PRESIDENT.
THE INFLOW OF THE INFLUX OF THE
KARINE JEAN-PIERRE LINK THAT IS
COMING THROUGH THE SOUTHERN
BORDER.
>> Jesse: BUT THE PRESIDENT IS
COMPROMISED BY THE COUNTRY THAT
HAS DECLARED THIS DRUG WAR ON
US.
HE COULD LAUNCH A CYBER ATTACK
ON THE CHINESE.
THAT IS WHAT I WOULD DO IF THEY
DECLARE A WAR BECAUSE THAT IS
HOW SERIOUS IT IS.
YOU CAN MAKE SO MUCH MONEY OFF
OF FENTANYL ON THE STREET.
YOU GET A KILO OF FENTANYL
$4,000 ON THE STREET AND YOU CAN
MAKE $1.2 MILLION.
COCAINE AND HEROIN AND METH, YOU
CAN EITHER MAKE CLOSE TO THAT ON
THE STREET.
AND YOU CAN'T TRAIN THESE DRUG
SNIFFING DOGS AT THE DEA TO
SNIFF IT OUT BECAUSE IT WILL
KILL THE DOGS.
HOW ARE YOU SUPPOSED TO TRAIN
THEM TO DO THAT?
IT IS A SMALL AMOUNT TO SMUGGLE.
AND TO THE POINT OVER HERE, THEY
BRING IN PRODUCE AND TAKE IT AND
BRING IT TO THE DOMINICAN
MIGRANTS AND CODED UP, MASKS,
GLOVES AND CODED UP IN PLASTIC
AND DISTRIBUTE IT TO BE HARD TO
DETECT.
>> Judge Jeanine: DANA, YOUNG
CHILDREN ARE GOING OUT TO
TRICK-OR-TREAT AND BASICALLY
PARENTS HAVE A DECISION TO MAKE.
DON'T LET YOUR KIDS GET THAT
CANDY BUT IT DOESN'T MEAN THE
PERSON GIVING OUT INTENT TO HARM
HERE >> Jesse: THROW AWAY THE
NERDS AND THE SWEET TARTS.
>> Dana: OR YOU DECIDE THERE
WERE NOT BE MASSIVE HALLOWEEN OR
SMALL GROUPS WITH FAMILIES THAT
WE KNOW AND WE WILL DO THIS IN
OUR BACKYARD IN OUR BASEMENT.
>> Brian: IT SOUNDS LIKE THE
PANDEMIC APPEARANCE BEFORE I
DON'T UNDERSTAND 300 AMERICANS A
DAY DIE.
WHAT DO WE DO WHEN COVID WAS
KILLING PEOPLE 300 A DAY?
WE SHUT DOWN THE ENTIRE COUNTRY.
IT IS AN EMERGENCY CABINET
MEETING THAT WE HAVE BY THE
UNITED STATES.
I CALL A MEETING ON THURSDAY
8:00 A.M. AND I WANT EVERYONE OF
YOU TO COME IN HERE WITH TWO
IDEAS.
HOW WE ARE GOING TO DEAL WITH
THE FENTANYL CRISIS AND PUT IT
OUT THERE AND LET PEOPLE KNOW
ABOUT IT.
ALSO WHERE'S THE EMERGENCY
EFFORT TO GET IT OUT TO THE
NATIONAL MEDIA?
THE DEA ONE KILL PILL INITIATIVE
AND IF I WERE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES, I WOULD TAKE THE
FULL FORCE OF MY CABINET AND
SAY, THIS IS WHAT WE ARE DOING.
WE ARE DOING IT ON THURSDAY AND
YOU BETTER BE THERE AND DO NOT
BE LATE."
>> Judge Jeanine: CHINA DOES
NOT HAVE A DRUG PROBLEM, I
UNDERSTAND...
BECAUSE THEIR PUNISHMENT IS
DEATH.
>> Sharon: IT IS DEATH.
>> Judge Jeanine: LITERALLY.
WHAT IS GOING ON IN THE U.K.?
>> Sharon: U.K., TOO, YOU HAVE
PEOPLE SELLING IT TO KIDS
OUTSIDE OF SCHOOLS.
IT IS EVERYWHERE THERE, TOO.
BUT THE THING IS, THESE PEOPLE
IN COURT SELLING IT SHOULD BE
PUT IN JAIL FOR LIFE.
THEY SHOULD BE SENT AWAY FOR
LIFE.
WHEN YOU ARE A DEALER, YOU ARE
KILLING PEOPLE.
SO YOU ARE A MURDERER AND YOU
SHOULD BE SENT AWAY FOR LIFE.
YOU KNOW, YOU CAN GET IT ON THE
DARK WEB.
I KNOW, I HAVE FOUGHT DRUGS MY
ENTIRE LIFE WITH MY FAMILY AND I
KNOW WHAT IT DOES TO PEOPLE.
BUT THIS HAS NEVER BEEN ANYTHING
LIKE THIS.
THIS IS INSTANT DEATH.
>> Brian: THEY WANT TO KILL
YOU AND JUDGE, REPUBLICAN
SITTING RIGHT NEXT TO
CHUCK SCHUMER AND A UNIFIED
PRESIDENT.
I DON'T KNOW IF YOU SAW THE
INAUGURAL BUT THAT WOULD BE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO GET PEOPLE ON THE
SAFE SIDE TO FIGHT THE SAME
FIGHT.
>> Sharon: BUT THEN LOOK AT
PEOPLE IN THE SENATE.
DON'T TELL ME THAT THEY DON'T
HAVE FAMILY MEMBERS THAT ARE
ADDICTS.
>> Brian: DOES THE PRESIDENT?
>> Judge Jeanine: HUNTER
BIDEN.
>> Sharon: YOU WOULD THINK THE
FIRST THING, I KNOW WHAT IT DOES
TO THE FAMILY, IT DESTROYS THE
FAMILY.
USUALLY, THE PERSON DOING IT
DIES.
SO WHY AREN'T THEY DOING
SOMETHING ABOUT IT?
IT IS DEFINITELY THE CHINESE
WANT TO DESTROY THE WESTERN
WORLD.
AND THE GOVERNMENT CANNOT -- ALL
OF THE GOVERNMENT CANNOT ALLOW
IT.
>> Brian: IT IS THERE WILL BE
OWED WAR ON US.
>> Sharon: AND JANA PAID ABOUT
THE BRAVES, YOU'VE GOT TO CHANGE
YOUR NAME OTHERWISE, THEY LOOK
TO DIVIDE US BUT THAT IS
ANOTHER ISSUE.
ANYWAY AMERICA TAXPAYERS BUT A